là ça bouge sur la route de villedieu
granville pour vous parler musique ce
soir avec un groupe de la région qui
s'appelle nine milian which is de la
musique rock mais j'aperçois sabine à
yale à equeurdreville hainneville qu'est
ce que vous allez nous proposer ce soir
sabine très bien c'est donc une
exposition nous ce sera de la musique
rock
c'est là où ça bouge et c'est parti
mélina eyed peas
dans la manche avec les nine 'million
witschi ça veut dire les 9 millions de
sorcières ouais tout à fait pourquoi 9
millions pourquoi 9 millions cette
histoire with any s'est pour sa part des
mois il ne reste plus que trois alors
votre grille sic a évolué un petit peu
au cours du temps on peut le dire ouais
en fait bas on a bien par rapport à la
paix qu'on a enregistrés il ya un an
c'était des tout débuts du groupe
c'était un peu expérimentale ferry
construit un style et là on est sur les
prises du premier album
donc on trouve un peu notre son et c'est
en train de vous en train de se
développer quoi
elle était
qu'est ce que vous diriez de votre
musique aujourd'hui c'est elle sur
comment ces coisy avant d'asséner ses
vieux rock alternatif on dit après c'est
assez gras c'est simple efficace en fait
souvent sous ce rapport il aurait de
solution c'est de la pop déguisés en
rock un peu
la la
prochain concert est l'album prochain
concert c'est au normandy le 5 mars en
première partie de inspector cluzo et on
a une date aussi pardon le 27 février à
hambye un petit festival
sa peine quand on se rencontre et la
sortie de l'album vers la rentrée
septembre octobre
c'est encore à définir
obstiné de style
sur des ardoises ordinaire qui coûte 3
euros
des artistes connus ou de simples
débutants des enfants de 3 ans ou des
mamies 87 ans compte ouvert leur coeur
et leur imaginaire ils ont joué avec les
ardoises de sophie j'ai commencé
personnellement à travailler sur des
ardoises en main propre en la priant le
support avec dépôt ce cas avec de
l'écriture des signes et des symboles
inventé et puis en exposant mon oncle
journal dont les peintres m'a félicité
et encouragé et comment alain biaux avec
qui je travaille à l'atelier d'art
contemporain m'a suggéré l'idée de
lancer un projet j'ai commencé par
solliciter des amis des connaissances et
puis par le bouche à oreille et les
réseaux sociaux
ça a fait boule de match donc voilà on
est à 3 102 aujourd'hui il y en a qui
arrivent encore il y en a qui sont
annoncés y en a qui vont arriver
c'est pas con i do l'île de key mais
voilà l'idée c'est ça c'est que ça
continue et la suite ce sera pour
l'exposition huit femmes pour le 8 mars
à thaon dans le calvados
et là ce sera des ardoises des artistes
femmes depuis un an déjà les ardoises de
sophie voyage elles sont posées à
l'espace hippolyte mars des coeurs de
ville jusqu'au 12 février